this is a production of Cornell
University let's talk POA peperomioides
propagation the palea peperomioides
plant or also the UFO or Chinese money
plant is a popular house plant with
coin-shaped leaves and I'm going to show
you how to propagate it here's some
materials you might need some gloves or
Clean Hands um sanitizing agent and a
blade some nice in soil I like one with
nice moisture holding capacity for
better
rooting and some plug trays or spare
pots next I'm going to show you how
we're going to propagate here's the
mother plant with a lot of little
offshoots or pups coming up around the
base we can also have these little uh
below the ground root cuting with new
pups that haven't emerged yet here I'm
going to remove some of the soil to make
it easier to access some of these cuting
that we're going to take here's a nice
cutting from the root we'll just come in
with a clean blade and Clean Hands and
take a cutting
here and there you go we have some nodes
for root establishment nice leaves this
should make a really nice cutting
there's also some cuting you can take
around the base of the stem here's one
as long as we have some nodes it should
establish just
fine next after you've taken as many
cuting as you want you can take them and
put them in the pot in media of your
choice I like this Pete Moss uh potting
media with a little pearly because it
has nice moisture holding capacity for
better route
establishment and here's some progress
shots so this is 3 days after the
initial cutting you can see some roots
coming out from where those nodes are
this is about 5 days after the initial
[Music]
cutting here we have six days nice root
establishment coming out of those nodes
and finally this is one week after our
initial cutting this should be ready to
grow and establish very well and enjoy
your new
plants this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu